that's it started here oh boy now I'm
loud okay so welcome to our regular
Thursday Thursday de maiz informatics
conference I'm Aaron Cohen for an
associate professor in the Department
for those of you who don't know me some
of these Thursday conferences we
designate as I dl talks and dramatic
discovery lab talks and if you don't
know what that is you can look on video
the talk that I did a couple weeks ago
and learn anything about you want about
the IDL but our ID l talks we try to
this is really loud I hope it's not
bothering anybody you know we try to
invite entrepreneurs luminaries experts
in diverse fields things you might not
hear in your typical informatics
conference I should say that we're well
okay so so today we have dr. John hurdle
who is both colleague and a personal
friend and a really great guy and he's
doing some interesting things and
informatics that I think are a little
atypical they're certainly leading edge
that I'm really excited to hear about
dr. Harrell's a professor of biomedical
informatics which over 25 years
experience in combined software
development and informatics research in
researching his bio and CV on the web
for this he got a bachelor's of science
and chemistry from Colorado in 1976 I
did not notice until today but get his
MD and his ms in computer science at the
same time in 1981 at Columbia University
of Colorado I don't know too many people
that are crazy enough to do that
including myself I would be crazy enough
but I didn't so he got a PhD in computer
science from the University of Utah in
1994 he served as an nlm informatics
fellow senior informatics fellow from
two thousand four to two thousand six
and from 2006 through the president he
has been faculty at the University of
Utah and biomedical informatics his
research interests include health
services research at the VA patient
safety research
adverse drug events and more recently in
clinical natural language processing all
of course at the University of Utah
several years ago driven by very much by
several enthusiastic graduate students
you have tell me about them he was
introduced to the nation field of
nutrition informatics today he'll make
the case that nutrition informatics
holds great potential to improve health
outcomes both the personalized medicine
and population health I am really
pleased to introduce dr. John hurdle and
I'm really interested to find out what
is nutritional informatics because it
sounds very new and leading-edge to me
so with that I will give done the floor
in the rest of the time please remember
we're recording this we're streaming it
you know the drill push the button if
you ask a question so it people at home
can hear you and so it gets recorded so
that not just the answer but the actual
question can be heard on the recording
Thank You Aaron am i coming through okay
can you guys hear me I feel bad for you
all I'm going to put a scoot over here
as far as I can so you can see that
screen at a bad angle Elizabeth said it
was going to be a small crowd i was
expecting 6 or 7 i'm delighted that this
room is full i know you came for the
pizza but i'll try to make this
informatics thing interesting and even
though despite what aaron just read off
in my bio that all sounded very
organized and planned but as we were
discussing last night at dinner it's
never organized never planned it was
very organic it just happened that I end
up in Utah which has the oldest
informatics program on the planet pure
luck so there's a lot of luck so for
those of you who are still students
don't over plan just but do respond to
the environment as it changes around you
so that's a very long title let me just
show you the people who work with me on
this i have a couple of graduate
students so first to their Philip and
volley and a postdoc and we just hire
their registered dietitian it also has
an MS in the statistics and she's an our
department of biomedical informatics we
work with a couple of nutritionists our
division of nutrition at the University
a marketing person who's interested in
health behavior change and behavioral
economics and then we just started a
collaboration with people up to you know
Utah State University which is our
land-grant institution now i'll talk
more about what we're doing with us you
and as we go through this so you may be
wondering well why is this thing about
nutrition and
informatics here at the idea well I
looked up the idea and I think there are
two of the sort of summary points that
this talk and our work speaks to
fostering highly relevant informatics
research on real-world problems like a
lot of people in this room I mean we all
write papers we all try to get grants
you know we make these incremental
changes and it it does help the
university because they get their money
and it helps us because we get some of
that money and we help students because
they get some of that money but as you
get further in this discipline I find
that I got more and more desperate to do
something that would actually affect the
real world as opposed to increase my
publication out on my H index so I was
happy to find this real world problem
and the other is uncover commercially
viable informatics opportunity this is
one of the core principles of the IDL
and as you'll see we think that there is
potential commercial application here
and please don't hesitate to ask
questions nutrition informatics is a
relatively unknown sub-discipline of our
field you're going to have questions we
have to ask them and if you don't all
start picking on Dave door so to protect
David ask me now normally a talk like
this you give a lot of slides or
justifying why you do think what you're
doing is important but really do I need
to make the point that poor diet is a
problem in this country this is a map of
incidence of diabetes very much
diet-related disease shows the incidents
by state in 1994 only one state South
Carolina had an incident diabetes
greater than seven percent scant 18
years later there was it only for who
had that and everybody else was well
above seven percent right so in that
relatively short period of time the
entire country slipped and the same
thing happened with obesity rates there
wasn't a single state in 1990 that had
more than fifteen percent by 2010 there
wasn't a single state that had less than
twenty percent obesity rate in the state
for adults so it's
a problem and it's it's not going to go
away and it's not just adults it's kids
as well in that in the last three
decades childhood obesity is doubled
there's some evidence now that's
flattening off which is a good thing but
adolescent rates have quadruped in that
period so we do need to find a way to
get nutrition and diet into the shared
decision-making process and we think the
way you do that is to come up with a way
a number a system hemoglobin a1c
equivalent and BMI equivalent to get the
discussion going if you look at epic
really carefully you'll find next to
nothing on nutrition that actually
supports things like clinical decision
support and that's what we're headed for
with this kind of work this is the state
of the art of nutrition counseling now
two people here have heard of the food
pyramid almost everybody well the USDA
threw that out and now they're talking
about what they called my plate which is
this thing and in essence it's you know
you want to spend about a quarter of
your plate on carbohydrates and a
quarter I'm protein a quarter on
vegetables and then other stuff like
like milk that's great for a plate but
it's really hard to actualize that if
the shopping center you have to take
this information and make that into
something you want to buy at the grocery
store which is where we want to operate
but that really is pretty much all we
can tell clinicians unless you're
trained dietitian how to advise people
with nutrition and diet so I'm going to
jump to the very end this is where I
want to be in the next decade so here's
the big idea people shop at their store
they ring up their sales receipt behind
the scenes the store almost every store
in the country now tracks stores and
tracks you pcs that are scanned and the
barcodes on the fruits and whatnot there
that are there people buy and put the
movie database so we want to take that
data out of the grocery realm and use
our tool which we call call mark the
quality measurement and recommendation
tool set to recommend back to the
shopper in whatever recommendations
style they want maybe it's a text maybe
it's a coupon
it's a menu maybe it's a shopping list
maybe it's a nap my 20 year old daughter
would want a nap i'm sure my 65 year old
sister probably wants a shopping list
but steer them into a healthier overall
shopping cart and then in a measure if
that actually affects health related
outcomes at the same time we're doing
that we think we because we can measure
this data over the long term
prospectively we can see if these
households are actually taking advantage
of his recommendation so if they are
will know it this will see the signal
change in the database of sales receipts
and then we can feed that back to people
who are interested in keeping their
customers their clients their patients
help you so major medical centers that
are worried about the ACO movement
willis programs health plans if all
these different groups have a vested
interest in keeping their patients and
their clients healthy am happy so i'd
like to see a system where they're
actually providing cash some cash
equivalent incentive to have these
households take our recommendation so
that's the big picture that's the big
personalized medicine it's not a bit of
a genome in there but it's it's real
world data that we think we can use to
help steer people into a healthier
lifestyle now well so we're arguing we
can measure this stuff and i'll show you
how we do that just a second from
grocery sales data what is the state of
the earth does anybody know really know
what the state of the art and figuring
out the quality of someone's diet
exactly right but this is the 24 hour
recall food diaries hand-written let me
zoom in on that so this says 715 one cup
T 1 cup skim milk one-and-a-half
teaspoons of white sugar most people
can't keep track of this so it takes
typically a dietitian to tease this
information out of somebody in an
interview some people are smart enough
to actually it takes a lot of work and
effort to remember all this stuff
another popular tool is called the food
frequency questionnaire and if you can't
read at the top does over the past 12
months have you
how many times have you had breads or
rules as part of a sandwich including a
burger one to six times a year seven so
you have to think back the entire year
an average out your bread consumption
and that's question number 65 so this
this is the state of the art now the
National Cancer Institute developed an
automatic 24-hour tool which is actually
pretty slick it's nice because not only
does it collect the information and help
you figure out what you ate but then
we'll give you a score called the
healthy eating index which I'm going to
talk about in just a second this has
never been validated in low-income
populations and we have a grant from the
USDA to do exactly that because you know
it is something I mean it's something
that is fairly inexpensive too because
it's online to get into people's hands
but still you can imagine I mean you
have a low-income family you're going to
but get them every week to sit down and
do this and how they going to do it so
we're trying to take the pain out of
things like this to make it as easy as
possible for patients and for whoever
your client or customer is the food
marketing institute is sort of the big
professional Society of grocery stores
there's some 40,000 retailers that
belong to it they recently published a
big issue on food and diet and quality
and this was their main graphic so cost
and lack of motivation major barriers to
eating confusion about what's healthy
what's not but that's getting we think
better let's unpack that just a little
bit the USDA would argue the cost is not
a barrier they have some very smart
economist who spend a lot of time trying
to show you that Americans can eat well
even on the budget and i'll give you a
glimpse of that in just a second so you
less days convinced that costs really
isn't the fact lack of motivation maybe
it's because we're denied so studies
have shown that the perception of most
parents only ten percent of parents will
admit in an interview or on a survey
that they think their child is
overweight or obese but in fact we know
that a third of them are so there's a
mismatch here right people are just not
fessing up to the fact that
that they've got a problem so part of
this lack of motivation is just really
lack of understanding and maybe denial
and in terms of confusion about what to
eat they don't think it's a much of an
obstacle anymore but I would argue is
just the opposite the proliferation of
apps you can find literally hundreds if
not thousands of diet related apps My
Fitness Pal being one very popular one
but others as well so trying to separate
the wheat from the chaff in that very
noisy app environment is is non-trivial
and that's where we think Walmart can
actually evenings here shouldn't two
things number first thing is where do
you see time in this because it may not
be costs or lack of motivation it might
be that i'm working 80 hours a week and
i can't do what it takes and the second
is if you could make just a comment
about the changing definitions of what
is a healthy diet high fat low fat high
power carbohydrate low carbohydrate this
is a bad fat this is a good fat you know
it's like this is all changed a lot over
the last 10 to 20 years and it's not
clear to me that it's stabilized or not
and that's true so Suton to your first
point sure you want to make this as easy
as possible for patients or customers or
clients absolute so that's one of the
things we're going to argue aaron is the
qual mart doesn't require anybody to do
anything except what they do anyway was
the shop and we'll show you how that
works your second points very well taken
so a lot of nutritional epidemiologists
think the reason that obesity race
flipped in this country from under 15 20
/ 20 across the country is because in
the 80s and 90s that all the really sort
of quote-unquote solid nutrition science
was saying avoid fats and what happens
is people replaced the calories with
carbohydrates and packaged food put with
along with those carbohydrates lots of
sodium and sugar and we began to eat
less meat and less fat and lot more
carbohydrate and sugar and a lot of
people think that's a prime driver for
that flip for the country so now they
have actually the brand new Dietary
Guidelines for Americans just came out
last year in 27
the point 15 every five years USDA
publishes sort of the current thinking
they measure what people are eating
through the CDC and Amy survey they know
what the enhancer be you wanted every
eat
exactly so every two years CDC amounts
is huge they send out literally convoys
of big big rigs at full of DEXA scans
they do a couple days of scanning of
what work all kinds of physical
interviews measurements calipers and
they do a nutritional assessment and
they do typically eight to ten thousand
individuals that are picked to be
representative of the current
distribution of gender and race in the
country and then they publish that data
and then USDA uses the end but so Ann
Haynes is the national sorry the
national health and nutrition
examination survey and AIDS and they use
that data to see what Americans are
eating and so that they do there for
couple years and then they come out with
new dietary guidelines because they say
oh we're not eating enough green
vegetable not eating in the whole food
based on that survey so this their
science behind this um but the errands
point so now in the 2015 guidelines they
totally be emphasized fat saturated fats
feel bad but they think that meeting
that aren't the villains that they used
to be added sugar is the big bad guy now
so now the ignis this big push from USDA
and other people to get rid of added
sugar and foods and drinks particularly
trigger sweetened beverages so my
response is erin i hope you'll see by
the end of this that the way were we're
organizing this shopping data lets us
change pretty nimbly its guidelines
change we don't really have to unchanged
the underlying architecture just some
definitions and this will make more
sense when i get into the meat the
models by the way how long do I have
okay
sure I tend to talk that so please stop
me if I'm not making sense to use you
got to throw a piece of pizza preferably
Hawaiian favorite we do have a
conceptual model I was hoping John would
be here I would defer conceptual model
because people who do science right
start with conceptual models this is one
by glance which is a tries to sort of
create a healthy nutrition environment
conceptual framework and where we put
our work and I can't read all this this
is a government community nutrition and
organizations consumers information and
then the actual socio-demographic
attributes of the house we we put
ourselves here the consumer nutrition
environment and over here in the
perceived nutritional environment as
you'll see all of our work is focused
not on individuals but on houses I'll
probably justify that as we move along
okay so how does this thing work so
you've all seen you know you all gone to
the store you scan right and all those
little you pcs and other codes gets
stored away along with the little
descriptor which appears on your sales
receipt it turns out we we team with the
largest grocery retailer in the country
the largest pure go to retailer in the
country walmart sells more food but
every day somewhere everything but in
terms of people who specialize in
grocery stores we team with uh with good
the biggest chain and and you'd think I
mean they've got to get these
descriptors this says for example
bananas which is fine this says bkr y SS
doughnut so they have to squish these
descriptive descriptive terms would be
really useful for us into these little
tiny fragments and we just assumed that
back home in the big database they had
linked this to a full descriptor all
kinds of information about the food but
they don't that's what they still in
their central headquarters there is so
we had to scramble looking at the web
trying to disambiguate these names and
that's a mapping question which is
probably more detail than you want but
anyway it complicates our life so we
take these sales data from a grocery
retailer we run it to our mapping
algorithms and at the
moment we're focusing on two different
models one is based on something called
the USDA food plans i'll show you a
picture that just a second and then the
USDA food plan world the USDA says
people who are on food stamps now called
snap benefits that's that's one budget
there's low-income budget middle-income
budget high-income budget they create
four different food plans depending on
how much money you can afford and what
to spend on food I mean they look at the
breakdown by gender and by age and they
come up with these tables that tell you
how much to eat if you want to conform
to the current dietary guidelines and
they categorize food into 29 different
kinds of food categories food groups if
you will the healthy eating index which
was created with National Cancer
Institute and USDA takes all the foods
and lumped them into 12 categories and
then scored them and gives you a measure
mother what you should be eating in
those components so it's two different
views one them for this will point
towards who plans and one we ran towards
us healthy eating index the key here is
with the one there are 12 different ways
of categorizing food and with the other
there's 29 yes ma'am the question is are
these based on what we would think of it
like a food group you'll see some
examples I know very little actually
about the logic how they decided to
break foods up into these twenty nine
categories for example for the food
plans I that's it's a little clearer
with the hgi because they were trying
specifically to take the foods from the
dietary guidelines that are based on in
haines and say okay we need to focus on
dark leafy green vegetables so that
becomes a category with the categories
with the food plants I have no idea how
they she asks a question which means you
guys and malice questions because got
that off the book for you and then once
we map these food these UPC's to these
different categories then we can
calculate a score and if we know the
past preferences that our family has
expressed you know if so if we detect so
if this is this is an example of what
the food plan
data might look like and if this family
was perfect that would be a flatline
they'd be spending exactly the right
amount of money on these 29 different
categories of foods but here they're
spending too much on refined grains and
too little on opens so we want them to
spend more on whole grains less here so
if they do by whole brains maybe they
like popcorn usta conserves popcorn no
bull ring or corn then we would
recommend look by more porn by less
wondering and we know what they like to
buy based on their past Express
pregnancy so that gives us some some
help to make recommendations and this
tells us what to recommend what kind of
recommendations to make here so the in
the bowl in the so you saw the big
picture we want to take those
recommendations Ethan back to family
measure to the extent to which the
hippie recommendations and then
incentivize them to improve that make
sense ok so the healthy eating index
later said it's the most widely used
metric these days in most nutrition
research has a very handy property it
applies to an individual you can apply
to a household you can fly to an entire
store I'll show you that in a few slides
down the stream here you can apply to
county any some researchers actually
from USDA published the healthy eating
index of the entire food stream of at
whole country people have published the
hgi and healthy eating index of taco
bell for example so it's very you can
imagine didn't do terribly well but it's
a handy metric because it's very
flexible how can be a fight and what it
does you can ignore the stuff on the
right foot for a second this it breaks
it these are the 12 components this is
the 2010 now that 2015 dietary
guidelines have come out they're going
to rethink this to get the ones that the
help us understand that those new
guidelines total total vegetables greens
and beans total fruit bowl fruit bowl
grains dairy told protein these are the
categories into which they score and
they score zero to five or ones that are
somewhat important ones that are really
important like dairy and
whole grains they score from zero to ten
and these scores these are negative
schools so the higher the score you get
here is the less of these things you're
eating these are the bathrooms these are
solid fats at a sugar and alcohol so
they're considered to be things we
should moderate as opposed to things
that we should try to buy more of that's
what the healthy eating index looks like
and the as ignore the thing on the right
mentioned that just a second so we and
map UPC's into these categories and then
using a very clever algorithm figure out
the HEI the score for each component and
just to give you an example here's the
score in this case for an entire
households 12-month shopping window in
the store in the upper middle-class
neighborhood in salt lake city called
the avenues and so the longer the bar is
and the greener it is the higher the
score I'm not saying that this is the
best way to display the score but it is
it does get the point across the smaller
the grayer middle smaller still read or
bad so there so this particular
household for that year is pretty well
with total vegetables and refined grains
not so well with seafood and protein
little bit okay with it with the whole
grains compare that household to one we
picked at random from a city called I do
it over in just a town we called Moab
which is in southern Utah to tourists
now I'm very seasonal people come in
they go hiking and they leave the great
on total protein but their meat but they
weren't eating whole fruits grains and
that's kind of what you'd expect but a
certain amount of face validity there
because the nature of this town is just
such that people come and go and the
whole town's economy is booming busts
great in the summer and in the winter
it's dead as a doornail so the shopping
quality there is by and large lower yes
ma'am
really insightful questions the question
was does the food map the food's map
directly into one to one so if you get
if you give me a UPC i can tell you
which code it should map to in the case
of the healthy eating index it maps to
i'll tell you what let me hold that
question at all i show you how the
healthy eating index model works and
then you'll see there's actually an
intermediate representation where we
distribute the answer is we do map at
121 to get another kind of category and
then in that category can distribute
like the whole grain part to this thing
and the the vegetables to another and i
think that will make more sense and
you'll see at the second yes ma'am quick
question on how you're defining
household like friesen example the food
in Moab is that people who live in Moab
or does that include purchases by people
who were in the web for a Viking weekend
right so the question was how do we
define household in this context this so
this is a the only way we have of
linking a given household to their
shopping history is through their
loyalty card this particular grocery
chain uses a loyalty card system and
they use it throughout the country they
claim that ninety six percent of their
shoppers use their loyalty card most of
the time so there and and that's
important to them because they that's
how they get customers to come back to
this door so in utah i get a reduction
in the price of gasoline tomorrow shop
at my smith store so it's they've got
every incentive to get shoppers using
that card the clerks you know say let's
see that card these are actually how so
this these are both household as defined
by that number so it's a 12-month
snapshot of everything that that
particular all the sales link to that
particular card for that family and
likewise in in in moab now you'll see
later some slides where we actually take
all the shoppers in the store and score
the store but here we're scoring an
individual
the questions he can come so what do we
do and what do we don't do you can begin
to see that there are some potential
limitations here well we don't miss your
dietary intake that is the standard
canonical approach include Tricia
mistake and I think this is one of the
values of this informatics asst we can
add to a field like this because we come
in not biased by how I was trained as a
nutritionist you know in college you
come into it as where's the data I got
some data what can I what can I do with
it so we don't look at it like
nutritionist so we get a lot of blowback
from people who are sort of
traditionalist because they're
interested in dietary intake as
cumbersome as it is with those recalls
and those who questionnaires they want
to know what individuals eat now they
know it's a poor to blunt tool that work
that they're using but they want to know
what the individual heats we would
rather take the approach we're more
interested in the quality of the
household food environment for lots of
reasons I mean it's it Prime's kids we
know this from studies of primes kids
for life it's it's it defines what
people can eat so I can't tell you what
that diabetic in this family is eating
but I can tell you the foods he or she
has access to and we think that's
important we look at the entire grocery
cart not individual just like snapshots
of selective foods set in the food we
look at the whole thing and and we can
do it over anytime soon so if we're
interested so we're doing a study with
USDA we're looking at month wats because
that's what they what they wanted to see
if there were trends at the level of a
month worth of shopping because everyone
shops differently some people shop
tically low-income people tend to shop
one big shop and then wait until the
next set of benefits come others shop
like I shop every other day its way I
shop so but this could this can be used
in any configuration not limited by the
the time span we don't focus on
individuals as I said okay so let me
help justify them just focus on the
household and not the individual so I
would argue that if you did a 24-hour
recall that would capture in the case of
Dave door it would capture that big man
key hand last night and the food he had
for breakfast and the pizza he had for
lunch today right so it's everything
both in and away from home but it's a
really core tool and it's really really
really hard to get people to do things
like right down there foods consistently
for any length of time whatsoever so
it's intrinsically not sustainable so
the good thing is that we said let's
take the thing we can measure with
precision which is shopping data and and
and see what we can do with that signal
it's an important signal at sixty to
seventy percent based on n Haines
studies of the calories that Americans
eat so it's a big chunk of what we eat
it's not everything but we said let's do
that really well then do individual
dietary intake badly and I would point
out we're doing work at USDA there they
don't give benefits to individuals they
give benefits to house they give
benefits to a mother who's got three
kids so that's that's where they're
trying to effect change which is one
reason we're interested in effecting
change there too and we don't there's a
product out of Harvard of course called
new valve completely black box no one
knows how it works it assigns scores
individual foods can't do a thing in
terms of aggregating we decided to stick
with just USDA I mean it's not a perfect
institution for that wears two hats it's
got to encourage agriculture which means
they're beholdin to big AG but on the
other hand they want to help us eat more
healthy so they're beholding to us it's
kind of weird but but their science is
really pretty good so we're comfortable
working with those data again Gorch our
data is is everything is the entire
market basket sixty percent seventy
percent of calories time span and best
of all is paints we're not asking
patients to do anything different than
what they do now eventually going to try
to encourage them to do what they're
doing in a more healthy way but they're
still doing what they're doing they've
got a shop so they shop and we help them
shop it it's unbiased I recall now you
could argue that if I knew I was being
monitored my health plan was going to
give me a fifty dollar a month
for staying on this thing either but
whole foods is not part of this thing
I'm going to go to Whole Foods and buy
my cake there and sort of and that's
possible and I you know the only answer
i have this ultimately we'd love to get
every grocery retailer in the country
participating with us and then there
would be no place to hide except
7-eleven and retrospective and
prospective that's really handy so we
can monitor compliance and also look
back to see what they like to eat and
it's cheap this story we got about 200
million transaction records from our
grocery partner didn't cost us a penny
because they already had it didn't cost
them a penny they just gave it to us so
it's very very cheap to get and is
scalable because virtually every store
in the country uses something like this
so it's got a lot going for this kind of
data is really pretty handy so how they
hell do we do this so we started off
with a very big data donation 15 months
ago she transactions 144,000 households
in four cities Seattle Salt Lake and
that sort of big area there atlanta and
richmond richmond was just thrown in
because it was it was there
unfortunately our partner does not have
a footprint in the the Great Lakes
region or the Northeast so but they had
strong presence in these four areas we
knew nothing about the households we
identified and we had very little
control of what they gave us you'll see
why that's a problem later so what does
this data look so I'm going to tell you
how it is the grocery stores organize
data and then make the case that there's
a really fortuitous coincidence here
that we could take advantage of so this
course we chain and we think most
grocery chains do the same thing because
they use the same basic structure from
IBM they break foods into departments an
example would be produce there in arc
and are in that in this gigantic data
set we had eight different food
departments there they armed grocery
deli meat natural foods produce drugs
that are they break department in the
commodities example would be buried
there's about here in 26 of those and
our data set there are some examples or
sort of by how many different UPC's I'm
and foods there are we get to take out
the wines because they were the top 15
unless it's not the case in salt lake
city for baby obvious reasons they don't
sell wine in the stores but they do
everywhere else and so in Seattle
Atlanta the wines were the most popular
so we had to take them out to get some
real food in that list Passover products
how about that there on the top a
value-added poultry then they break
commodities into sub commodities for
example blueberries there's almost 2,000
of these sub commodities through the top
13 again ranked by UPC's Mexican
software to use and wraps I mean it's
you know the kitchen example of the kind
of foods there and then finally you get
the actual food itself which has a UPC
or peel you code like bananas 4011
that's the code for some blueberry and
there's about 92,000 in this data set of
this thing foods hey what do you think
is the number one food that came out of
15 months of sales Seattle Salt Lake
Atlanta and Richmond for a 15-month
period wait no why did if we didn't
count water what is it Fred coffee milk
the number one was bananas by a factor
of two the hardening thing about this
list is at the top 13 or so these are
all pretty good foods right that's not
what there's no junk in there I mean
there's low-fat yogurt these limes
there's avocado strawberries eggs that's
pretty encouraging I think I this is
based on transact this is baseless so if
you bought one banana that would be one
banana if you bought five bananas and
put them on the scale and typed in 401
one or the clerk did that's one safe so
that's transactions that include bananas
and avocados right right behind there
no the question was are these foods are
only available to people who some point
you can buy with snap food stamps in
some food you can't and no this is all
the foods that are in this universe of
140,000 household and again they was
much easier for them just to give us
everything from these districts as
opposed to trying to do a query to you
were delighted oh sure give us all your
data no problem with that so just to get
I won't dwell on this too long this is
what the data actually looks like we get
a bunch of info on the item itself like
it's code it's the things I just talked
about right the department that
commodity the sub commodity this
descriptor this thing is the universal
UPC codes called the g10 then a base
thing and then this descriptor and then
we added this is this a food or not we
had probably four hundred thousand
different kinds of things that people
were buying at these stores only about a
quarter of which were actually foods
they gave us information about the
transaction like which household it was
the time to date all the usual stuff and
really importantly they don't tell us
like if it was a loaf of bread or a
package of Cheerios they don't tell us
the size of that box obviously didn't
very consistently but they did tell us
how much it cost and you can do a lot
with that cost figure it turns out i'll
show you later and then they gave us
information about the store including
the longitude and latitude the geo codes
for the store and from that we map that
over to census tract information and
there you have all kinds of data about
the environment around the store so it's
about any socio-economic rear but you
can imagine that the Census Bureau
tracks can then be tied knot to the
household but to thee to the store now
as we go forward with consented families
who are giving us their data we will
have their geocode we hope and then we
can do more precise studies about the
environment around those households but
there is to know a lot about the
environment around the store so what do
we do so remember we talked about the
food plans and the HEI to make the HEI
model work we actually map from UPC's
over to something called what we eat in
a
Erica food categories I know this is
just fascinating i love this stuff but i
know it's kind of work so there's 150 of
those and we had to add 12 more because
when they came up with so this is the
way that they categorize foods for
enemies this is what that's all about
this is via codes and for some reason at
back in the beginning they didn't think
to break up whole grains from fine
grains but now we have to do that so we
created our own pseudo codes so there's
160 two of these categories in 29 and
the food plans so then the goal is to
map all these UPC's over there and we
lucked out because it turns out that the
way grocery stores conceptualize food is
very similar in a lot of cases to the
way nutritionists conceptualized food I
mean a banana is a fruit and fruits are
in produce and you can exploit this
homology and in fact we could map at the
level of the sub comps remember there's
departments commodity sub commodity we
discovered one of my bike graduate
students discovered you could map by
ninety percent of the sub commodities
directly to these two routes we account
avoids in food plan categories without
doing any manual review I'll show you an
example the other ten percent we had to
map by hand but that's a lot easier to
map 10,000 than the map 100,000 and
because codes change for example a
decade ago you would have been hard
pressed to find Greek yogurt in the
store now it's everywhere energy drinks
were relatively obscure 10 15 years ago
now they're ubiquitous so you pcs calm
and go foods come and go so we want to
want something that's sustainable and we
think that in the future as we add more
stores and add more UPC's we can still
exploit this lucky pretty lucky homology
between grocery store organization of
food and nutritionists i'm just going to
throw this out here for anybody who's
really into food so usda also has this
thing called the FN dds which is an
acronym for something food and nutrition
database for dietary studies i think
and there's about eight thousand foods
in that if you go into your computer and
type into Google how many calories in an
Apple Google is looking here a lot of
the base codes based foods and my
fitness pal start here almost as we
began to look at apps and look at the
kind of data they came up with we can
tell because of the numbers they got
that they're starting with this freely
accessible open database called f in VBS
and what's nice about it they provide
the crosswalk directly to these
categories and they have is kind of hard
to see but everything in red up there
these are of macro and micronutrients
for every hundred grams of these eight
thousand foods so it's really handy if
you want to get into really if you try
and like emulate the DASH diet for
example where you're really concerned
about sodium this can tell you a whole
lot about the food so we're interested
ultimately and mapping from here to here
but that's proven to be harder than we
thought we haven't solved that problem
yet but you think it's worth doing in
the long run [ __ ] is sort of a footnote
so once we've mapped all those you feces
down here then we can generate these
scores from our two models give an
example about this homology so in the
case of blueberries that's actually a
subcommittee Margaret and I showed three
examples here there's a lot more down
here frozen different I mean I don't
know why they choose different pose but
there's lots of different fruit codes so
we don't have to worry about any of this
detail because we can map it directly
here either that we a category or that
food plan category and then if they add
more blueberries it doesn't matter you
get another grocery store and they have
different codes but they belong to
blueberries we've already got it back so
it has a built-in we think sustainable
future this just mapping approach here
is it affect if you know how its
prepared like you could buy peaches or
you could buy canned peaches and heavy
syrup and how does it handle that so
canned peaches would crop up in a
different sub commodity and a different
commodity I don't know up top my head
where they would be and but you're right
our nutritionist consider
even though the people in this room
might not consider canned peach to be as
good as a regular peach or canned corn
to be as good as fresh corn for people
on a budget that's actually a it's an
important economic distinction but it's
not an important nutrition distinction
at least according to dietitian so they
would love you to eat fresh if you could
but if you can't afford to do that then
it's better to you can corn then can't
then then then carmel clear gifs is that
so they would be in a different
commodity sub commodity so I won't dwell
too much on this that when USDA first
created the food plan so again these are
oriented by budget like are you are you
in food stamps low middle high and
they're telling you essentially how many
pounds of something to buy a week and if
you just bought all these pounds of
stuff for the 29 different categories in
here there's like 10 of them you have
everything you need to have a healthy
diet but then that would have been great
but we didn't get it might recall we
didn't get the amount the actual like
how many ounces of Cheerios or pounds of
potatoes that somebody buy but we did
get the price and luckily USDA has a
very has exactly the same thing only
broken out by how much percent of your
food budget should you be spending on
these 29 degrees because we have to
spend we can calculate how close they're
conforming to these food plan tables
because we have actual mom that he was
better
the HEI model estimator it's a little
trickier so I was designed by one of our
postdocs who came out of computer
science she was a numerical modeler we
took a lot of the data that was
collected and and vetted for the in
Haines study i mentioned before the sit
like we took twenty thousand households
worth and essentially looked at if they
were buying just based on counts this
much in this leah category in this much
in this via category what was their
overall score for full fruits or
whatever and because that was big enough
it turned and this was the hypothesis
could we just go directly from counting
up how many hits we had in these via
categories and then seeing that there
was a relationship between that count
and the actual hgi scores which is what
that thing does we can get an estimate
and it turned out to be pretty good we
validated it and here's the results we
ever for some reason she decides she
wouldn't do chromevox the Alpha was not
a good choice so here's the Pearson's
correlation so you see we do pretty good
so this isn't measuring our model versus
the actual so in n hanes there's
actually a calculator because they have
the nutritionist dietitian figuring out
exactly how much people are eating if
you have that then you can calculate the
score this is away from home but we're
interested really in foods at home so
those correlations are pretty good I
mean they're really strong in here
pretty good pretty good and of course
they collapse here and this gets to your
question from before for this particular
model these so the ones where we do
badly refined grains and whole grains
were bad because we discovered we had an
error in our map and we fixed that but
not before this we published but this
thing the fatty acyl rachel which are
trying to get out how much saturated fat
you mean compared to all the fat you're
eating sodium and empty calories because
we don't have amounts we can't really
get can extract we cannot extract these
nutrient phase measures to just we just
can't do it very well so we're really
good at the things that people should be
eating it's harder for us
get at how badly people are getting with
these nutrient based components so we're
still working on how to you know trying
to find a way to work around that
well this so the question was how do we
even come up with even a baddest of her
sodium because we're not actually
measuring sodium and let me just if you
will bear with me run back to this sorry
guys I think it's a really good question
don't count added salt well so the food
at home you know I don't know that's a
good question i'll tell you what i don't
i went to get back to one image but i'm
gonna have a card compatible so uh
that's a good quote about added salt so
the way we get around this is because
we're counting up the number of hits in
how many times people bought food when
the grocery data or consume food and n
haynes we we know how the people in n
mains how their sodium their added sugar
all that stuff distributed across these
categories and so although that tends to
work well with things that you can count
like fruits and vegetables it turns out
that using the distributions that were
implicit in the in the end Haynes data
just didn't do a very good job and i
don't think we're ever going to do a
very good job with with those sorry but
it turns out that the 2015 guidelines
have kind of de-emphasized sodium that
at least raise the the you know this is
probably heresy to a hypertension doctor
but it's you know it's not as critical
but we really want to get at the added
sugars that's our next major goal do we
know that's going to become important
and then someday so we I just walked you
through all this is what we do you know
we'd like some day than to add like the
Mediterranean diet it's a special
modified Mediterranean diet for
Americans the harbor put together I'm
not so sure about dash but anything that
we can map into these USDA databases we
can calculate because we've already
figured out how to go from the grocery
to the USDA so basically now it's a
problem as we want to add new kinds of
metrics during out how to map those on
to the USDA and because we have the
underlying architecture for the for the
grocery stuff ok we're doing a study
with USDA a little tiny study in Utah a
much bigger one in five states where
we're looking at this may surprise you
the government gives a lot of money to
USDA to give people
food stamps now called snap benefits and
the USDA doesn't have any way really to
measure how well people are doing on
food stamps so they offer nutrition
courses something called snap-ed and
ethnic courses to help educate people
about nutrition and diet and exercise
but they don't have any way to evaluate
the courses themselves I don't know if
people are actually learning from their
courses so we're you know it's I think
it's a good thing that we're helping
people with with with snap benefits I
think it's kind of alarming that we
don't know if education interventions
are actually working so USDA give us a
grant to use walmart to figure that out
so we're going to be looking at
recruiting families from these five
states who are participants in snaps and
there's a control arm in the whole works
looking at what they bought 12 months
before the intervention of classes and
then 12 months after the classes to see
if there's a change hopefully we'll see
detect a positive uptick in overall
quality in certain areas and we'll be
able to say if the persists lasts over
time and if it doesn't then USDA knows
maybe there's something they can do to
fix those courses or to improve how they
help people on food stamps eat better
the kinds of applications that we
envision in the clinical world we see if
you know we're not here yet we just wait
everything you've seen is stuff we've
done I hear stuff that we'd like to do
we'd like to create some kind of visual
graphical indicator and if anybody here
is really a whiz-bang a graphical
display of numeric data we'd love to
talk to give people an idea you know
patients how they're doing and maybe if
they're getting rewards how the rewards
are doing families like yours got 15
points why don't you get you whatever we
behavioral economical tricks we can use
could be a smartphone that even in our
low-income population the vast majority
of people have a smartphone device you
guys use the epic so maybe it's
something we could stick into my chart
don't know the best way of doing that
yet we also see a set of apps for
we'd like to make nutrition beta which
is not completely absent from the HR
first class data citizen so you can
imagine it would be useful just to see
it in the context of things like blood
sugar and sodium what not but we'd
really like to use it we think to get
people talking good clinicians and
patients talking about food and saying
gee you guys did great on your total
foods last year but now you're still
eating a lot of added sugar let's work
on that you know and then next time you
see that person you know maybe my chart
can ping them or whatever I mean the
idea is just to get it in there and
let's see how clinicians and patients
actually use and we haven't really done
any work internet although i have a
graduate student now one of her PhD aim
just due to a user-centered design study
with clinicians in art the Pediatrics
department to figure out what it is you
know this is really tricky I mean it's
one thing to ask clinicians you know how
would you like to see a hemoglobin a1c
for a year or display you know they can
they can imagine that when you want to
see nutrition or food displayed they've
got no framework they can't even suggest
so we got to figure out how to create a
enlist clinicians to help us help them
display this data in some way that's
actually useful and quickly
comprehendible just like a flow chart or
something it's now an epic and it's it's
an interesting challenge illustration
purposes only I mean you can imagine
some kind of app you guys then a couple
of I'm almost done just a couple of kind
of fun facts about hei so we measured
the healthy eating index using the hei
model estimator this is a the salt lake
valley that blue thing is the second
Salty's body of water on Earth Great
Salt Lake there's a mountain range here
and these are stores the bigger dot is
the more household shop there and the
greener it is the better the overall
score you can see there's this kind of
pattern move Wes the scores get Taylor
and yellow
and that pretty much maps to the
economic the income distribution in the
valley it's it's as you go west
literally west of the tracks the income
level drops and there's a red dot there
it's kind of interesting let's zoom in
on that red dot it turns out this
grocery chain so here's the avenues we
saw that shopper from the Avenue store
upper-middle-class neighborhood pretty
big it's big and it's pretty green and
then is this big red dot down here turns
out that that this portrait chain also
has a chain of gasoline convenience
stores so they actually do sell food and
they do tie them to the shopper card and
all they sell there is junk through the
course because it's a convenience store
it's a gas station little and it's nice
that that showed up because it had been
a really dark green we would have been
worried here's a comparison of overall
dairy scores and hei has a dairy score
it's an important score this is again a
slightly bigger picture of what's going
on in Salt Lake just for dairy so it's
kind of hard to see there's some pale
ones here and then a lot of greenish
ones Seattle Seattle a little less dairy
a lot more fading stuff in the middle
here and a lot more pink pink pink
circles and that's pretty much down by
the harbor and then Atlanta then there's
this big chunk lack of dairy now if you
were a public health policy maker we
think this kind of information might
actually be useful what's going on in
those neighborhoods why isn't there more
I mean when I showed these screens to
the guy who runs our university dough
has his own health insurance plan Gail
plans he said you know what I do is I
start putting billboards up in these
neighborhoods got milk or whatever I
mean anything to just to get dairy on
the minds of people and we think that
this might be you know a useful use for
the hallmark technology again it's free
it doesn't cost it may cost us more
computation time but that's cheap to
calculate all this stuff so it's because
it's scalable we think this would be
useful across the country what else we
have your um so when we do our
comparisons between our tools and in
haines they come up good but and we have
a gold standard in the intense data
itself they can enhance can tell us with
the HDI is for there for there for there
respondents but when it comes to
actually measuring households or stores
we don't have a reference standard
there's no gold standard that tell me
how my family is doing in the avenues
because there just isn't any comparable
gold standard so we look around for
things like face validity like that
convenience store but here's another
study one of my students did it's it's
known the literature that smokers eat
more poorly than non-smokers so we
decided to see if we could see that so
we took a random sample of sixteen
thousand households in that big data set
and broke them up into two categories
households that never bought any tobacco
products of any kind and those that
bought at least one tobacco product at
least once and that 15-month period
which is like like the most extreme
definition you could get and it turned
out that indeed I hear higher sports are
better and every time you see an aspect
that's a significantly higher score and
overall their overall estimated hei is
almost ten percent higher so we
replicated the finding from the
literature with our tool and right now
we don't know any better way we can't
really prove that we're getting at the
overall quality at the household level
because we don't have any other way to
measure it as a comparison but we do
studies like this to convince ourselves
that we're getting the same results that
you would expect from other studies in
the literature and there is the actual
distribution this is the people who
don't clearly ship